what's going on patrons and general
members of the rob corp we're gonna make
this video public because it's just it's
too good right it's just it's a
ridiculously good video plus i want to
advertise to the people on the youtube
channel the versus videos that we do on
patreon and stuff like that having said
that patrons um i'll have a huge update
for you today there's something really
cool that we're working on behind was a
bunch of cool stuff that we're working
on behind the scenes but i want to show
you guys like some behind the scenes
stuff that i think you guys might dig
right so uh so be on the lookout for
that today but we are back again with
another installment of our versus series
and this week you guys have gone with a
battle of two of the most powerful super
villains that the marvel universe has
ever seen the chaos king and the marquee
of death i mean just those names alone
right let you know that both of these
guys are capable of causing some massive
destruction right like one guy named
himself after death and the other person
named himself after chaos it's just kind
of nuts but the nature of these guys
will become even more clear as we go
over their origins and powers as we
always do which is what i will do right
now so the chaos king was created by
michael ohming and first appeared in
thor blood oath number six in 2006. now
his real name is amatsu mikabashi and he
is named after a japanese god of evil
and chaos that has the same name and
that was basically all that was said
about him when he was introduced now
later that year oming wrote a mini
series called aries god of war which was
stupidly good and it fleshed out the
chaos king's character a whole lot more
so what happens in that series is that
ares the greek god of war leaves olympus
to live a normal life and raise his kid
one day he's visited by the messenger
god hermes who says he needs to return
to olympus because it's facing a threat
unlike anything it had faced before and
so ares refuses and then zeus kidnaps
his son and takes him to olympus to get
ares to return now when ares shows up he
finds his son has been kidnapped by the
same threat that he was asked to help
defeat the chaos king amatsu mikabashi
now what we learn is that following the
fall of asgard mikabashi who has existed
for billions of years was inspired to
destroy as many pantheons of gods as he
could and since he had already subdued
the entire pantheon of japanese deities
he'd set his sights on the greek gods of
olympus and to that end we see the first
of chaos king's seemingly endless list
of powers on display as he transports an
entire army to olympus to battle the
gods and we also learn that his armies
are made up of those that he's killed
before so he's able to resurrect those
that he kills and then force them to do
his bidding now in another display of
his power the chaos king is able to
mortally wound zeus the most powerful of
the greek gods and a character that's
roughly on par with odin give or take a
little bit who is of course an extremely
powerful character in and of himself but
after zeus heals he confronts chaos king
again but his attack is completely
ineffective and chaos king rips his
heart out of his chest now following
this the chaos king was seemingly killed
by airy's son wielding a mystical sword
known as the grass cutter blade although
that death was going to be exceedingly
temporary and we would see him
resurrected after a few years now after
a brief period where mikabashi posed as
a good guy he ends up subduing the
scroll slave army and begins a path of
destruction across the multiverse that
will play out in the 2010 chaos war
event which we covered here on comics
explains and here we really get to see
how powerful the chaos king is as he's
able to kill several pantheons of gods
including the egyptian celtic and shia
gods as well as the gods of the silver
surfer's homeworld zen lot he then
ventures to the dream dimension and
kills nightmare the longtime doctor
strange villain that rules over that
dimension which causes almost everyone
on earth to fall into a sleep-like state
he also goes to hell and literally
destroys satan before casting the deity
of death out of hell as well and keep in
mind this is the same death that was
able to control thanos when he had the
infinity gauntlet now when satan's
defeated the chaos king releases the
souls of the damned from hell and allows
them to run amok on earth under his
control now the few heroes that remain
on earth hercules thor and amadeus cho
try to find anyone they can to help them
defeat the chaos king and they appeal to
the cosmic entity eternity which is the
living embodiment of all life in the
marvel multiverse now eternity informs
them that he cannot fight the chaos king
because the two of them are two sides of
the same coin meaning that while
eternity represents the concept of
everything the chaos king represents
nothingness so it would basically be
like eternity fighting himself now
eternity goes on to explain that if the
chaos king is not stopped eternity
himself would cease to exist and
nothingness would reign supreme so when
we talk about chaos king we're talking
about one of the most powerful entities
in all of normal comics and he's on par
with a cosmic abstract eternity now
eventually the chaos king is defeated
but he's not killed he was able to
survive a battle with cersei who was in
eternal galactus silver surfer and
hercules had been made nearly omnipotent
by some ancient artifacts collected by
amadeus cho and was only defeated by
being transported into a bubble
dimension of nothingness after galactus
and amadeus cho opened up a portal and
hercules punched him through so this
guy's nuts here's the crazy thing about
the chaos king he's considered an aspect
of oblivion so if chaos king is this
powerful imagine how powerful oblivion
is now luckily we have a character that
fits the description of someone that
could give chaos king a running for his
money and that is the marquee of death
so the marquee of death is the eventual
alter ego of clyde winchum who was
created by mark miller and tommy lee
edwards and first appeared in marvel
1985 number two and 2008. now marvel
1985 was a mini-series premised on the
idea of marvel superheroes showing up on
earth 1218 which was supposed to
represent our world where superheroes
simply don't exist what we find out here
is that actually one mutant exists on
earth 1218 and that's a kid named clyde
winchem who is a reality warping psychic
who suffers from a traumatic brain
injury after being hit in the head with
a candlestick by his mom when he
accidentally brings his father back from
the dead now clyde is a fan of marvel
comic books and when his books are taken
from him in the nursing home he lives in
he gets pissed off and uses his reality
warping powers to summon the marvel
super villains to his universe so they
can punish those who had wronged him now
he ends up sending them back to where
they came from by simply uttering the
words enough and later clyde is found on
earth 616 the main marvel universe of
course by reed richards who places him
in a comatose state where he constantly
experiences pleasant dreams and puts him
in a holding facility called area 87.
now the marquee of death is a possible
future version of clyde winchum from an
alternate universe that escapes that
alternate reality version of area 87 and
has his mental faculties repaired by a
group of supervillains that come to kill
him but of course clyde ends up killing
them with a single thought now again
that's one thing to know that the story
of clyde as he originally appeared ended
in the main marvel universe the story of
the marquee of death picks up with an
alternate reality version of clyde whose
story is basically the exact same and
then things transpired in the way that
we just discussed now this act awakens
in clyde an insatiable desire to cause
destruction and since he's able to warp
reality to make himself immortal he
spends billions of years learning to
control time and space and evolves into
the marquee of death traveling
throughout the multiverse and
eradicating each universe he encounters
now much like the chaos king the list of
powers that the marquee of death
possesses is practically endless both of
them are immortal entities that have
lived for billions of years and both
border on omnipotence meaning they can
both do basically whatever it is that
they want so trying to come up with a
comprehensive list of their powers is
not really possible but just to get an
idea of how powerful the marquee of
death is and this is gonna blow your
mind honestly i think this was more
impressive than the chaos king at one
point he has a chess match with a
younger version of his alter ego clyde
and the pieces they're playing chess
with are some of the most powerful
characters in all of marvel comics like
thanos odin ego the living planet
mephisto galactus and even eternity so
the fact that these characters are
literal plaything for the marquee of
death shows us just how absurdly
powerful he is now with so many videos
where we have two characters this
powerful it's always hard to
definitively say which one would be the
winner because you have two characters
that can practically do anything they
want the main difference between these
two is that the marquee of death has the
ability to warp reality and as powerful
as a chaos king is he does not display
that ability he can manipulate matter
and energy and can approach omnipotence
by absorbing the power of gods and all
that together can come close to
replicating the ability to alter reality
itself but he doesn't seem to be able to
manifest whatever he wants out of
nothingness the way the marquee of death
can't so the marquee of death's reality
warping ability is a major advantage
even when going up against someone as
formidable as the chaos king but that's
not to say the chaos king does not have
his own advantages and in fact i think
he actually has the edge in terms of
durability that's kind of odd to say
since both of these guys are pretty much
invulnerable but the fact remains that
the marquee of death was eventually
defeated by dealing enough damage to him
sure it required him battling another
version of himself followed by taking on
an army of fantastic force from multiple
realities in the human torch reaching an
unprecedented temperature of 100 million
trillion trillion degrees kelvin to
weaken the marquee of death enough to
negate his powers and render him
vulnerable but it's possible now the
chaos king however seemed to be
invulnerable to energy attacks from
galactus silver surfer and nearly
omnipotent hercules and had to be
removed to a pocket universe to be
defeated because those extremely
powerful characters could produce enough
energy to actually harm him but at the
end of the day this battle could
definitely go either way as both of
these characters are multiversal threats
in fact both of them had destroyed
countless universes without much
difficulty by the time we see them in
their respective run-ins with the main
marvel universe and i think this comes
down to what parameters we set for
winning the battle here in a fight i
think more likely than not the chaos
king wins as he should be able to endure
whatever damage the marquee of death
dishes out and eventually over an
extremely long period of time can
probably deal enough damage to get the
victory but given the marquis of death's
reality warping powers we have to
remember that he could just remove the
chaos king to a pocket universe or
simply will him out of existence so
while i don't think the marquee of death
could technically kill the chaos king in
a battle i think he could get a victory
here by simply just removing him from
the battlefield but let me know what you
guys think i could definitely see this
going either way right so let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section but make sure you guys check out
patreon we do versus videos like this
all the time and patrons make sure you
keep an update or keep a lookout for the
update that i'm bringing you guys and i
will catch you all later
peace